philosophy is supposed to be this study
of the big questions right an Aristotle
is going to talk a little bit about how
we ask questions how we and we enquired
the questions how we form arguments you
know the sort of school which would
approach them but one of the things that
we should reflect on before we look at
the some of the topics is what are these
big enduring questions that never seem
to get it turns out that a lot of these
are things that we bring up in
philosophy we don't necessarily solve we
talk about some people's proposals for
solving so what are they what are the
big things that life is suffering life
is about preparing yourself for death
that was the Phaedo - about him joining
us answers
what happens after the body yeah people
been preoccupied with disparate various
little kids ask this first funeral a
pentagram where is she now is she ever
gonna come back she okay
those were there's pretty big questions
aren't they one way to tell the things
are big questions is when somebody asks
you that your kind of loss
you feel satisfied what else there are
other big questions or ancient Greek
times the gods exist or is this all just
poets fancies
these are all okay yeah although I want
that one
presupposes a whole bunch of other
questions song but you've got chickens
to get eggs that's our stuff that's
really a question of origins you know
asking why things happen the way they do
let's call that the question of priority
what actually does come first
he's a good representative punch I think
there's a lot of other ones
there what is
yeah do we have any purpose is are we
distinct from the other animals or you
know there's no one's tithing some like
the meaning of life is like meaningless
if it is we don't have any goal but if
there is some meaning and maybe we have
to figure it out what are things that
you have been puzzled about and feel to
be sort of pressing questions in your
own life they haven't found really
satisfactory answers for yet or
personally based existential questions
I'll give you
I have somebody who had a strong
existence why well I was I get angry too
so it means seven anger problem right
get angry the wrong time wrong you know
wrong reasons wrong people that sort of
thing well why is that
why are some people calm and other
people you know like fly off the handle
like that is there is it good to be
angry so bad to be angry
is there any happy medium there we get
some more personally oriented things
don't where are the things that you're
worried about yeah somebody try to be
good question
why why is there so much bad stuff in
the world why do people do the wrong
thing even if they know something well
why is it world unfair that's that's an
existential question that's that's not
just sort of you know sitting sitting by
yourself and saying what was the nature
of causality what's time you know when
you really adapt it all of you all of
you feel I think this is sort of the
press of the question of evil on you at
one time in your life you've been
treated unfairly you see people get away
with it what the hell why why does why
does this happen
I've been good why do they get to do
that to me but then you don't need to
report it to somebody and they say life
is not fair
this is even worse and you wonder it
alright is there anything good
along these lines maybe not all of us a
Sara Lee dance stuff are there any any
questions at puzzly about things you
experience you haven't found Santa's
Factory answers yeah well sometimes I
wonder why I like people go to school
and go to work and like why we're all
doing this and how it came to be like
that as opposed to others okay
part of that is like beginning of life
once what's the point of it but you know
think about that you know in this
classroom I mean isn't necessary that we
actually have like a chalkboard and a
lectern and a professor here and
students sitting in desks there is there
something like inherently necessaries of
automatically the best way to do
education why do we do this who are you
stood let's say some people actually
need to that's very true there's some
people
they may not get it the explanation is
not there to the personal face-to-face
time yeah yeah I have a lot of
colleagues who are like wild about
online learning and I actually I teach
out my classes like design online
classes but they're not a magic bullet
they're not like they're not for
everybody like you say there are some
people who need very structured
environments or something to that do you
think that's the reason why all these
professors on all these classrooms have
things they either set it up like this
or how else do they do
that's lard-asses how what do you like
circling your desks dude I want to be a
painter like your desks well how do you
why do you eat it yeah today I'm sewing
so yeah I only get more stuff but the
students are involved with more so the
professor's still the one like teaching
them and speaking like that professor
rule rather than everybody's kind of
contributing and discussion type of
thing you learning that way I think
there's something to that because when I
would have you know ask students about
that sometimes they say well you know
you're getting paid to teach us
presumably you actually know something
more than we do and you can you could
articulate it there's something to that
yeah
so you know somebody may produce any
even that clips yeah I mean there's
something I actually learned quite a lot
from interacting with you guys through
discussion and then reading your papers
lots of examples actually enjoy myself
yeah notice what we did there is we took
a wrong kind of question and we're not
particular eyes dit into the situation
of Education we're actually doing what
when Aristotle's dialectic now these are
all sort of big questions we can ask
other ones you know what is beauty why
do we like the things we do what's
happening when I fall in love is there a
difference between Bob and other things
all these are sort of big and enduring
questions and where do you go to find
answers for these these sorts of things
that ties in with this question why they
remain where do you go to find answers
when you've got questions like these
there's a lot of the places this is
research okay so where do you reach the
library okay Onix Peter well would you
type it what would you look up or what
sort of what sort of database okay
so history is one place to go to solidly
text religious beliefs your elders yeah
scholarly texts include history history
of is when it's done well is actually
full of reflection on these bigger
questions you know for doing a history
of the civil war you have to ask
yourself questions like why are we so
violent how could slavery have remained
in place for so long it was felt to be
an injustice by period to ask big
questions religions offer a lot
answers to these sorts of things the
more you dig into them the more you find
that each each religion ends up having a
lot of different sort of schools and and
you know some emphasize this fact that
someone emphasized this and they don't
always agree with each other that's kind
of kind of fund it investigate your
elders do you find your owners
particularly helpful with do you have
people you can actually go to it I'm
worried about the meaning of life or
whether the God exists or how this whole
thing came to be do you have others that
you can go to and say hey this has been
bothering ya for certain questions yeah
I think it seems had to it's hard to use
as elders or anybody here because nobody
knows anything for sure so maybe more so
like this ends of a discussion and like
confident ideas with somebody else but
when it comes to looking birds aren't
answer or solutions impossible because
nobody really knows well there's a lot
of people who think that they they know
they're willing to give you answers but
they may not actually you're onto
something there and that deals with this
question of how he how he actually
grapple with these and this also
actually has to deal with the question
why did you remain open for a lot of
these questions there is a there's a
personal element to it I don't say it's
like totally subjective
just got their own answers and we all
have our own little truths like we're
all in these little bubbles that don't
interact with other people's bubbles but
there is a dimension to a lot of these
where yeah you're your own where you are
you're your grounding your perspective
your experiences your reflections your
growth matters quite a bit you know this
question any other desert god or gods
there are philosophical arguments for
the existence of God there are some
philosophical arguments against the
existence of God and we'll look at some
of these later on in the semester I know
a few people who've been convinced by
philosophical arguments for the
existence of God and became you know
believers and God afterwards I don't
know a lot of people do I think
oftentimes it does take some sort of
personal experience but actually when
you ask them why did you find this
argument convincing turns out there's a
personal dimension yeah you know when we
look at some of the arguments for the
existence of God then you find out well
here's what God is the prime mover or
you know the first cause I don't know
what I want to have a relationship with
the prime mover I want to have a
relationship with some sort of God I
think it's gonna be something much more
interactive than that right so yeah
laughing that personal grounding that
personal center maybe some of these
questions don't mean so much question of
evil
like I said when do you actually start
asking that usually let's somebody's
screwed you over or when you see other
people suffering and you're like this
doesn't make any sense these are good
people why are they suffering where you
see evil people get in the way of things
that's when it strikes home so that sort
of leads us into this you know why why
do these remain open questions and part
of that her the introduced
part of its going to have to do with the
fact that the aerosol doesn't really get
into this too much maybe it does
you know demand some sort of personal
existential they would say grounding or
senator making it your own that's why
some of these questions don't don't
really get home for a lot you know are
there ways to handle these questions and
then not to have to deal with them never
again I just find some belief system
stick to that and you know anytime
somebody says something different just
go now and then you know worry about it
or just find some activities that keep
you really really busy keep you nice and
distracted then you don't have to think
about this stuff right people do that if
you drink enough you won't think about
these questions too much the
philosophizing that goes on in jim marrs
not that varies icon caliber usually
it's not really philosophizing my
experience but if you actually start
paying attention to things you're living
a life that actually has enough room in
it for thinking about this you're gonna
start asking these these sort of
questions and you know again it's
philosophy the only the only discipline
that deals with these history does to a
certain extent
I deal with these kind of things what
other ways might these questions be
resolved yeah science that's a very
tempting answer and some of these
science can give us partial answers to
it when science can give us answers
they're usually pretty good they're
pretty solid for what they talk about
politics no in what sense like my photo
editor well like how did society into
play business well you know we vote in
our politicians on articles you know
whatever their yeah whatever we agree
with what they say they're gonna do so
there's that it's both human beings they
kind of yeah what's good and bad are
long compassion yeah I don't know that
you can you can solve all these just by
staying well whoever's in charge
resolves these satisfactorily for us
because if they did then the answers
would be closed off and it wouldn't have
to worry about well I think there are
certain political systems where they
they actually tried to do that totality
realism that's part of the impulse
behind totalitarianism we've done with
these questions everybody's going to get
along and everybody's going to shut the
hell up
it is totalitarianism right now you rank
the politics will often is an attempt to
try to solve these sorts of things
what about literature what makes great
literature great literature raises a lot
of these powers you know it doesn't have
to necessarily be these questions if
you're reading classic literature like
you know the Song of Roland what's that
about that's about loyalty what is the
nature of does it demand that you stick
around and die or would it be okay to to
get the hell out of there while the
getting's good
don't die necessarily
what's the nature of pride you know
valor that will serve the little things
that are raised that people actually
make speeches about it when you read
Shakespeare Shakespeare is chock full of
asking questions like this not
necessarily giving it definitive answers
but you know raising these sort of
things Brandon's gonna raise those
questions a lot of science fiction and
fantasy raises these questions mystery
novels sometimes if they're deep enough
to raise these questions so what else do
you think I couldn't talk about give us
where do we do people trying to work
these outlets or canvas literature all
right
yeah a lot of cases are kind of depends
it yeah
music particularly music is essentially
poetry put to music if it's songs right
poetry is a way to try to make sense out
of these things so all these different
disciplines kind of have a lot of common
with with philosophy and think about
love songs for example all the different
views that you can get from songs about
the nature of law some of them are
really good some of them are probably
not smart to rely upon what do you think
are there any love songs that you can
think of that you've got man I don't
think that's really got it right and I
probably should not follow that idea
they're giving an answer to something
but it's probably the wrong answer no
this is a mistaken answer at least for
most cases these remain numbers all
questions not only because there's a
personal element in part because there's
there's so many answers and here's where
we start to get to that
yes when we get to aris lakis actual
text topics dialectic is going to be one
of the ways in which we try to address
these big enduring questions but it's
useful for a model of advice and we want
to know what dialectic is how does
Aristotle define it he says that it's an
art or a capacity or a method or a
discipline that teaches you or gives you
resources for examining arguments for
finding out how to make arguments for
looking at other people's arguments and
seeing whether they hold anything or
whether they're you know flying spotting
BS that falls apart when you actually
try to wrap something at it whether your
own arguments are like that he says
really four main things about so it's
systematic systematic in in the sense
that you're actually trying to connect
things up together you're trying to get
somewhere you're trying to develop
things that you can use not just in one
context but in other contexts well so it
has to do with reasoning and we'll talk
a little bit about what that means
because that's that's one of these terms
oh we all read it right but there's
different
something aristotle uses his term
civilizing and he doesn't necessarily
mean that if you've run into this sort
of thing like a logic class he doesn't
necessarily mean syllogisms
you know with three you know two two
premises and one conclusion type of
stuff is a little bit looser but what's
going on with reasoning is in part you
know testing things looking at that
things takes its starting points in
certain kinds of propositions certain
kinds of assumptions certain kinds of
opinions beliefs yeah dialectic is also
so you know so go back to this issue
about you know can we get our also
answers from science let's think about
the different sciences what are what are
some examples of different sciences
biology yeah these are the big three
that we usually teaching in high school
and there's a reason why because these
are really foundational things what
differentiates these three Sciences from
each other they have different subject
matters they may actually use some of
the same procedures some of the same
tools yeah there's one another certain
we kind of have like specific you're
gonna get or what's happening you're
talking about but overall what they
focus on it might be parts of so to
speak like life or the world
well only one of them focuses on life
itself which wishes well what she does
to innocence though because all the life
is exactly those are the building blocks
and then physics too as well because
it's all of our surroundings yeah but
only biology demonizes life does live
enhanced the question what is it to be
living as opposed to be dead chemistry
right contributes a lot of organic
chemistry and particularly contributes a
lot of concepts I feel like with a lot
of topics in science there's like the
biological way to explain something or
like the chemical something like the
physical way yeah I think like they can
have different perspectives on the same
thing yeah you know chemistry is looking
at the basic elements that everything
can be broken down and how you can put
them back together
attractive that's really what chemistry
is it's basic physics is the study of
motion and change and yeah these these
elements are emotion themselves physics
contributes to biology and chemistry and
chemistry contributes to biology biology
is taking a kind of higher-order view
physics isn't so much more basic what's
more basic even than physics that's
that's not necessarily even connected
with the physical world that we have to
have in physics mathematics right
another yet another kind of study and as
you go past biology are there any other
sciences that look at other phenomena on
their ranges of subject matters while
sociology now you have this again
individual living things on one's life
what is society and there are kids a lot
more messy and actually by holidays more
messy than chemistry
chemistry's more messy than physics
physics is more messy than mathematics
yeah just going to say that you had one
situation and judged by all three of
other scientists you get a different
response for the cold you had say yeah
sometimes I saw them but hopefully
they'll get a lot of most of the time
right for instance like if you had say a
guy pushing a car a physicist who looks
about the emotion of the man actually
being able to move the car in the
distance okay point A to point B a
chemist might look at how energy is
converted
where a biologist would not just look at
it is a man pushing his car they looked
behind the behavior of why he's pushing
this car psychologist and you know we
have all their sort of offshoots like in
the anime what does an anime concern
pretty simple Bobby right yeah what are
all the different parts and it doesn't
really worry that much about some other
things that biology memorize these parts
and how they fit together then he'll use
that for something else
medicine uses biology right the medicine
the same thing as biology it's been a
somewhat different emphasis on health
right so the the topics is about
dialectic and dialectic just straddles
all these different subject matters if
you want certain kinds of the answers
that biologist is the person to go to if
you want other sorts of answers maybe a
historian is the person to go through
and if you go through the historian
about the biologists off you better hope
that that historian knows a lot about
biology because they're going to need
that or they answer that question but if
it's a historical question then you know
going to a biologist probably not gonna
be very helpful is it once that
biologist habits also be an arbitrary of
story and it works that way with a lot
of other things people will often go to
the scientists for all sorts of the
answer
philosophical questions but the
scientists not only generally aren't
equipped to handle but don't realize
that sin that equipped to handle so it
ain't up to you if you watch the news or
read the papers or or you know looking
online you're constantly seeing things
about you know the science of morality
the scientists don't actually know much
but they know a lot about physical
phenomena and then they extrapolate from
that to in very sketchy ways you
actually look at - making all sorts of
judgments about how this affects our
views but then when you start to look at
it when you start to do dialectic with
it these things tend to unravel when you
start asking well why did you make that
assumption well that's just what we do
in our discipline we just want to
actively assume that dialectic doesn't
assume anything this is part of what
makes philosophy different we don't say
well why don't do biology we have to
accept these postulates and we're never
going to question them or even ask why
we're just gonna say look you accept
these these are part of the textbook now
let's go do biology even mathematics is
that there's philosophy isn't and it's
in part because of all these these other
things this is the part of it that's
really central to dialectic this is also
what allows us to distinguish it from
other feelings other types of study so
one of the things that we're able to
distinguish this from is the sciences
were the arts or the other you know
disciplines that handle specific kinds
of being specific kinds of phenomena
they they're really good at what they
did usually by this point in the game
right they're really good at handling
this the historian is really good at
providing historical explanations for
things but it may now
historical explanation biologist is very
good at providing biological
explanations for things but that may not
cover all the stuff that you're
interested like you don't think about
love biologists have some views on love
don't they are they going to be
satisfying to you across the board and
explaining it of your entire existence
probably not over the long haul
historian can tell you well the idea of
love changed over time and here's the
courtly love came in and all that but
you can still ask well yeah that that's
that's great now I understand how that
how it developed which kind should I
have that's a different kind of question
business so it's different from these
other subject management's begin with
their elements or postulates
it's also different from what we call
demonstration and a lot of times when
we're dealing with these tricky open
philosophical questions we would like to
have hard and fast answers why what cuz
we're human beings you know we want
certainty don't we especially if it has
to do with you know questions with them
am i doing the right thing wouldn't you
like to be certain about that rather
than yeah I'm probably doing the right
thing but I might hurt a lot of people
in the process when do you really be
certain I think you would should I love
this person or not that's a big question
I mean you can really screw up your life
loving the wrong person you can take a
lot of time to recover from that
decision well there are some things in
which we do have certainty though
there's other things in which we we can
only have you know sort of best guesses
and we can provide arguments and the
kind of reasoning that dialectic does is
not demonstration in the sense of
providing a certainty because it doesn't
start from starting points from
assumptions from promises that everybody
totally agrees on across the board it
begins from from you can say somewhat
contestant somewhat generalized starting
points it's different also from what
Aristotle calls eristic or we might call
it in a rhetoric in a bad sense or they
also call this sophism so the
sophistical arguments arguments where
somebody is trying to get over on
somebody else for their just mistaken
about it and they're beginning from
starting points that look like they are
generally sometimes people do this
because they want to get over it you
know sometimes people do this because
they they don't know any better
maybe they're so rooted in their own
culture don't realize that anybody else
sees anything any different way so
they've never thought about things
differently and they just make you know
big assumptions like like that
so dialectic is different from these
other things well what is it so this is
where we get to this important generally
accepted opinions or what we get what is
that so something is generally accepted
that means not everybody accepts that
are there some viewpoints say about good
and evil that most people accept but
some people say now that that's all
wrong
their need sort of common accepted
assumptions about how to how to behave
as a decent person in society you would
say most people you run across would
agree to helping unfortunate people is
okay if you guys agree well most people
think that helping unfortunate people is
good not everybody does think that right
some people think screw they've got it
coming to them that's a different belief
thankfully in this society
most people don't seem to think that
some people actually think if somebody
else does you know in a bad situation
you should take it the energy that's the
good thing to do again thankfully not
too many people think that most people
think you see something falling down we
should help them up that's a good thing
that's a generally accepted opinion in
the realm of ethics yeah that's a good
one thank you you follow the speed limit
hello I like to go it's kind of funny
because now you ask about this is my
ethics class most people go over the
speed line as a matter of fact people
driving the speed limit it takes most of
us long and now you ask people well why
tell the we have speed limits that and
you know you get also text but I need
cops need to do pull people over but
then you ask them one more question say
well what do you think is the limit what
do you think that it wants to be over
the speed limit
after that you're driving recklessly
most people say ten over and so if
you're going ten over you're probably
okay cop might pull you over but you're
probably you know driving in a fairly
reliable manner and you can't stop
hit anybody if you're going 15 over 20
over 30 over now you're being reckless
and you know they should come down there
you're dealing with some generally
accepted about our society I don't think
that you could generalize it like go say
to to Spain and find the exact same
things it probably even across United
States I don't really know I can tell
you in the places of a group that seems
to be fairly constant so that might be
another example of generally Holland's
opinions um the arts people - yeah
there's something about honesty about
the value of truth that most of us
recognize - all of us recognize it no
otherwise you know we would have liars
we would have pathological liars we
wouldn't have some people that lie so
much that they don't even know we know
after a while which is the truth and
which is I know lately it's generally
accepted opinions those could be
opinions that are accepted by almost
everybody they could actually be
opinions that are accepted by just about
everyone but they're not primary in the
sense of like you know just immediately
clear to people they're kind of murky or
this work it's really interesting
Aristotle says they might not be
accepted by everybody they might not
even be accepted by the majority but
they would be accepted by the wise in
the translation that you have it says
the Philosopher's but it really
shouldn't say the Philosopher's it
should say the wise which is the so
close the person who possesses some
degree of wisdom they don't have to
necessarily be philosophers as a matter
of fact I can tell you from my
experience with people who studied
philosophy plenty of unwise philosophers
out there as well but there are wise
people in other contexts historians
poets can be wise artists it all really
depends and we don't have any commonly
across the board accepted test for who
actually is wise to business so that
raises some other problems but do you
have experience in your life of fighting
some people to have more on the ball
than others not just with respect to
like you know they're really good at
history or science or making a buck or
something like that
but they seem to have an understanding
of the world they seem to have an
understanding of how people work they
seem to be able to figure things out
better those would be the wise and now
you know there's the wise that we know
and we're in contact with and then
there's the wise who are part of our
culture for the Greeks the poets some of
the important poets would be part of the
ones poetry had a very different
function so Homer if you actually read
Homer he uses a lot of really smart
things in there every once in a while
then it's not just poking eyeballs out
and you know stabbed two people with
Spears and ships and things like that
there's a lot of discussion of things I
think Shakespeare would qualify as well
otherwise probably Shakespeare's you can
find anything anything you want to
justify you can find somebody doing it
so it's kind of but he's company or the
color wax no in any direction you like
where else do people turn forward stuff
are there any sort of yeah yeah
hopefully there
there lies overtime you know the ones
that are plies we tend to forget about
you like for example one of the things
that gets brought up every election what
did George Washington think about the
identity political parties yeah and did
he say I don't like parties I'm not part
of kind of guy did he give any reasons
for it see this is where we would start
getting into dialectic you could start
from the beginning plan George
Washington one of the wise said we
shouldn't have political parties we do
have political parties were probably in
a bad state you're making an argument
that and if somebody says yeah why'd
this guy say that well presumably he had
some reasons for that and the process of
dialectic would be exploring those well
that seem do those reasons still apply
to our current situation or do we need
parties Washington thought they were a
bad thing because they they tend to
produce a lot of animosity between the
people and they eventually can get to
places where you can get anything done
where it's liable to break up the
Society is that a live issue I don't
know that the Democrats and the
Republicans are actually gonna engage in
a civil war at one time so presumably
there was something saying so you know
we can start from starting points that
are opinions otherwise they might
sometimes be things that all the wise
agree on you know all the political
leaders agree on but not necessarily
that people do they could be things that
are held by some of the wise usually you
want to get those you know the most
notable ones the real heavy hitters on
your side II don't want to quote say
well James Buchanan said there's nobody
really knows who he is right
what's your American history buff he was
I can't even tell which one he was I
think he was he was before the war but
I'm not even sure about that I'm Shane
there there you go see somebody else is
better informed than I am comes to
Buchanan things you want to you know
talk to somebody actually knows not just
somebody who thinks this might be the
case so if we begin from these sort of
starting points that's part of what
makes it dialectic and now if we begin
from these starting points what do you
think is going to happen when you when
you start thinking along these sort of
lines are you coming up with an answer
that will be convincing to everybody in
every case I think it's kind of
persuading yourself but sometimes
depending on what kind of person you are
into the border I'm accepting but
willing to at least listen to what other
people say may brought in your opinion I
think you're right about that there's
there's that actually like sort of feeds
in there's two things you so they feed
it for the elements of this one is if
you make an argument if you start from
sort of commonly accepted views Geordi
the wise you come up with some sort of
argument some sort of reasoning somebody
else would come up with a different one
and you want to actually like hear them
because they're probably working form
telling they accepted opinions or
they're working from opinions that seem
to be commonly accepted but they're not
like they got what George Washington
said wrong they're misinterpreting
other people say or they're using
biology in some sort of weird way that
biologists wouldn't say his kosher and
dialectic can help you with that but if
they're making arguments that are drawn
from other you know plausible premises
then yes you do have to be open-minded
and you have to be willing to say yeah I
guess you know maybe there's something
to what you're saying and generally if
you look at the Eric model what he does
he will say okay so for example do
people ever do wrong knowingly
this is a live issue in ethics do people
ever know that they're doing the wrong
thing while they're doing the wrong
thing or are they necessarily mistaken
about that you can make arguments on
this side you know what our argument
would be from experience yeah I mean I I
know I've done that before many other
people seem to agree that we can do this
some of the poet's have talked about
that Aristotle wouldn't have access to
this but if you are biblically inclined
you could say you know st. Paul actually
talks about this the good that I know I
do not going to do the evil on the other
hand Plato and Socrates seem to think
that whatever somebody does wrong it's
because they're actually mistaken about
things they actually don't have
knowledge full knowledge that they're
doing the wrong thing so now we've got a
contested problem an issue right and
arguments can be made on both sides this
is part of why these issues remain open
now if you want to actually not
necessarily even do philosophy if you
just want to be you know educated
intelligent a good problem solver you
have to be able to see what's right in
both of these yeah and where they fail
Aristotle when he deals with this
question will actually say well it was
right about some of these things some of
these things now all them so they'll
make distinctions they'll say well he's
right about this he's right about this
but he's wrong about these points that's
that sort of like coming to a compromise
all right I'm done with the other side
let's say well they're right about this
they're right about this but they got
this wrong too now we put them together
and we've got a better account it's
really drawing on everybody's resources
and you can do the same thing for any
sort of contest the topic what should I
do when I fall in love a lot of places
you could get commonly accepted opinions
and reason to things about but then you
should actually look at the arguments
that are being made and now another
thing that you've said that Aristotle
thinks is very important it's not just
about convincing other people it's about
figuring out what you in fact think
about these things so let's go back to
the political parties thing maybe your
guys are just sick of our politics hi
sugar sure I can't myself vote for
either party and no no third parties
really are you know attractive to me
either because there's something wrong
with most of their platforms as well and
I you know I just you know the party
platforms I don't like the way they do
things I don't like the stranglehold
they have Thanks and so I might say well
you know George Washington is right well
is that really the best reason for
meeting in 2013 to be saying yeah
there's something wrong with the party
system George Washington said so maybe
not maybe when I'm thinking about this
for my own reasoning for figuring out my
own believes I should bring in as many
points of view and then look at them
critically analyze say well they were
right about this but wrong about this
dialectic is part of how you yourself
whether your philosophy whether your
politician scientist Weaver
you know musician pick whatever you like
it's how you can actually start to get
clear about what you in fact believe and
why you believe it and not just about
you know clearly defined topics but
about these messy open philosophical
questions that turn out to be the most
interesting ones for our our lives these
are what he calls dialectal problems
anytime that there's a matter of where
the case might be made for different
ways of looking at things we have a
dialectical product so dialectic is is
very good for these sorts of things the
last thing that I mean did it to bring
up this is a little bit of contest
problem there's a lot of things that he
talks about in this book and this this
section and the topics I want to get on
these four concepts that he brings up
these are useful tools there's other
useful tools as well because the Meno
wasn't that concerned with definition
how do we define virtue what is virtue
he also talks about the property genus
an accident if you want to be able to
argue well if you want to be able to
think things out though these are useful
categories to to place things into to
use to identify what somebody else is
saying what you're tempted to say
response and then to analyze so what was
the definition Aristotle says the
definition is
essence what is the essence the essence
is
let's try to define this what is this
okay that's good it's a cookie thing
what kind of cookie things specifically
let's go my breakfast Katya if I don't
want this Kody somebody's got a bacon
gotta be me right
plus they charge like you block
something for something like this I can
make tons of them she so we've got this
thing now you substitute you right so
that actually is in part the genus miss
Cody disabilities are a kind of quickie
what makes this different from other
cookies yeah okay that's important the
essence for a cookie I guess would in
part be the shape the taste
we might be might talk about the
ingredients taste comes from I don't
think we're gonna get much further than
that and when you come to the essence of
a cookie right because we're now talking
about deep stop here the essence of
freedom or the nature of the person
we're talk about a cookie but this
illustrates it well okay so it's got to
be a oblong shape he's how do we
describe this is tough to do this but
we'll say sweet but not too sweet
crunchy anything else you can say about
this Cody yes I suppose you're right who
would go through that yeah what else
would you say about anything else I'm
missing that I'm leaving out its
problems okay so should crumble a little
bit yeah that the atmospheric or double
baking process gives it a hard crust
okay so that's good we now define miss
Cody
the genus is sort of you know class
that lots or different things did they
all have some things in common what if
cookies all have in common
it'd make some cookies some ingredients
say they should have them count although
macaroons at all I'll give you a hint
cookies yeah and in French there this
because you bake them alright there's a
baking process and they are dessert so I
suppose you could say usually they do a
flower maybe a coconut we might define
them in part by purpose therefore eating
after something like that right well
there's a lot of different cookies that
fit in there we want to talk about
mammals what is the what makes mammals
mammals laughter live birth or blood
what's up with you said which one leave
the Platypus out lactation here yeah
those would all be things genus is
so it's not as close and the property is
going to be something that other things
and the genus don't have and now you
might say well how is that different at
all from definition well let's think
about this before we do that su casa
what does the accident anything else you
can say about the chalk what would you
say about this chalk you can talk about
its essence it is made of some sort of
calcium I'm not even sure that the
composition is trusted what's up calcium
calcium carbonate yeah pressed into a
shape used on the chalkboard that's
essential to chalk genus I suppose
writing implements I don't know the
accidents in my hand right now
there's nothing essential about it being
in Hannah we can bounce none in my hand
right now it's in my pocket
chalk can be in colors the white is not
necessarily what makes the truck of
yellow chalk works just as good right
properties are things that belong to it
and only to that can't die what aren't
Leah session I don't know that we'd
actually have any was charged but
if you had to define human being how
would you decide you to that is in fact
what aerosol uses rational animal that's
the one that gets passed on through
philosophy that's what he thinks is a of
our essence and now notice genus animal
there's a lot of different animals
we are the animals we have the we have
all the other things that animals
essentially have locomotion moving parts
blood circulating in this region or
something like that basic things
digestion excretion reproduction all
those sorts of things right but then
what's distinctive from from what
distinguishes us from the other animals
rationality we're able to think out of
much higher level doesn't mean cats
can't problem-solve bag they're not
actually like reasoning it out you can't
catch talking pros/cons with cats also
gonna ask themself am i a bad cat or a
good cat they don't care but are there a
lot of other things that are distinctive
to us as human beings and other animals
don't have that you could say where
other things
okay and oh you know it's interesting
Aristotle thought animals have souls
they just have a diet like death souls
the principle of life but yeah a little
sayin of mortals that could be a thing
that'll be around a contested point but
look look at things we can actually
observe yeah okay yeah now you know if
we did operations on some animals maybe
they could walk around afraid before the
time being we're pretty much the only
game in town when it comes to that and
that's another possible way of defining
us the aerosol the featherless biped
birds walk on two legs
what more distinctive to us well well
adapt what about this kind of adaptation
creation of tools yeah we might actually
say advanced tools because we know that
like chimpanzees will stick a stick into
the the anthill like you know getting
ants out to eat them and there's debates
about whether that's tool-making otters
and smash you know rocks onto the things
they want to open up that's kind of like
a tool but we actually they don't make
icons right they don't cook biscotti in
there so technology the other animals
land
hyenas yeah the data laughing sound are
they actually laughing at a joke that
wouldn't be that wouldn't be our own
property yeah you're right
well monkeys and the higher a bussiness
of yeah it makes the sound but it's it
maybe we could say humor but then again
yeah you're right
monkeys hire ava seem to have a sense of
humor and almonds actually too but you
might have something to do with
intelligence with rationality what about
religion human beings started burying
their dead and distinctive poses as far
as we know I think something like fifty
thousand years ago all dairy animals do
that the animals rex rinds
to the cat god the doggie god they go to
church on Sunday once we break them know
that maybe that's distinctive you can
think of a lot of things that could be
properties of us without necessarily
being the essence of us here's the thing
I'd like to leave you with we're
thinking about it with respect to this
those things that are distinctive to
human beings like a sense of humor
technology making religion do they have
anything to do with our asses sort of
that would be one of those big open
questions in philosophy
they usually actually go and find out
what other people thought about see
whether you think there's anything to it
if you're doing that you're doing
dialectic